so you're you're you get this experience
in fifth grade where you basically say
you don't want to learn russian they
they crack down on your mom
your brother your sister yes
did you at any point were you so were
you so
you you saw what happened between your
mom and your dad you'd been told
your whole life that communism was evil
did so did you just kind of suppress
that a little bit to
to keep from getting taken away from
your mom
uh i did but maybe not intentionally
really at that time i was not political
i was just like
i was just annoyed that i have to have
the language that my grandmother tells
me those people are
not really good and they don't do good
things in poland they
uh they are prayers poland so i don't
have to learn that language
so there was nearly not so much
political but the state was very
political the state was
very uh they were very cautious with
citizens
they wanted to control and they did
control almost every aspect of social
life that's what socialism is
and uh so that didn't really that
the the political part came later when i
started learning about the mortars the
political murders the oppression
of socialism uh and uh
tedward has became a little bit more
aware of what's going on
then reading about the people
disappearing from the street
and like never heard from them again uh
that become a little bit more then i
became more aware
and so then
in late 70s in poland it had
so much so enough of these lies
because what happened is we had the
empty shelves there was nothing to eat
and you can't buy food you can buy
clothes you cannot buy food insured
but all you hear how great is in poland
in socialist system
if you look at america people are
sleeping on the street and they
you know had no access to an information
they showed those tents or they saw
those sharks where poor people sometimes
stay or they show the worst thing about
america
so that that was just people
knew that this lie so they got so fed up
that
eventually no matter what that socialist
press said
people didn't believe they say that this
is this is
brown people think they know that
they're lying even if it was brown
this is how they hit enough it had to
explode
and that that thing was accumulating
fantastic people lost the faith in in
the government
they lost their faith in the the truth
that wouldn't the truth
that the lies that are being told they
stopped paying attention to it
so at the end no matter what they said
people didn't believe they had enough of
it and it exploded in the
solidarity trade union movement where
that people just raised up and say
enough is enough
we had enough of socialism and communism
when you're when you're um growing up
you talked about fifth grade
you're in eighth grade you're in ninth
grade
you're in tenth grade and i know we're
gonna end up talking about this at some
point you learn how to fight
like not just what you you learn how to
street fight and you learn how to
fight on some level did you what did you
train you trained taekwondo did you
train boxing what did you train
i started with boxing just regular
boxing and i remember you know
being just my mom growing up uh
my younger brother and sister so
sometimes i had to fight
for my brother too it's quite often
and so the box boxing was
important for me to kind of like uh
codify what i
already knew to just learn maybe this
technical skills now
and it worked great i mean i really
liked it but then
uh again so my brother got beat up at
school i think because
we're divorcees so there's people just
so i always remember i was sick
and uh i said well i need to go to
school then i just pack my stuff i went
to school i found the big guy that guy
was like
huge so i just knock him out and and
knock him out so bad that this this guy
show up with his mom later in the
evening in my apartment and it's like
he's like see this your son
did that to my son he can lose his eye i
mean i look at the guy from like behind
the
corner and i was like holy [ __ ] the guy
has no eye he's like
big swollen hey and so my mom just kind
of coming in
and she's like look at me i'm like half
of his size and this guy
is huge and he's crying so uh it's like
so that guy bit your son i was like yeah
yeah you see what he did to him
so if your son that big let him happen
to that i think he deserves it why don't
you just guys leave
so um yeah they left was there a boxing
gym was there a boxing
yeah there was one there like actually
there was a program or something there
was official program yes
actually there was the police club i
didn't know about that time but
the clubs like this were on usually by
the police
so so yeah i bought that they call it
guardia so
so yeah i belong to this club but when i
nailed this guy i broke my hand
i didn't know it so that put me and so
some of my friends went on their
first boxing matches and stuff i just
they had to stay home and
okay then we just moved to different
towns so but that was my style was with
the boxing and i liked that
i got involved in the eventually
taekwondo and
this kind of find the story too because
my attitude was a bit different and the
taekwondo they practiced in poland at
that time there was there's two
different type of taekwondo
itf wtf i so we did the itf there's like
no covering or anything just go and took
it out uh
so we went to the first polish
championship
and i didn't know any better they put
this thing on me i was like how do i
fight with that but okay
so i just keep knocking these guys out
just keep progressing
so i get every time i finish my fight i
say is
you have minus points for the being
brutal the airport if it's brutal you
can do that
so so i mean it was like it was funny
and the final fight
uh final fight for the first place i
knocked the guy out
and there's so the guy's laying there
the guy
the judge comes to me saying you you're
being disqualified
from the program you i mean not quite
disqualified
but he's the winner so then you know
they announced okay this is uh the
winner is saying so
right here the guys are laying there
passed out
so i was like okay well but anyway if i
guess there was i was not very though
my fight was not very sports like
because i got a lot of weasels and
booing after
i went this is a second to take my
second place
and that kind of ended up and then you
know the the prison came in and uh
actually they helped me a lot in prison
i'm glad that
uh i was able to help other political
prisoners there's a friend of mine
who actually i met again when i visited
poland recently
so um since i didn't have anything to do
up there just sit and
we just just you're solidarity i'm so
dirty let's go train
so we're training he said look what you
did to me
help me later survive the beatings that
i got from the guards and that
and all that stuff